about uh 25 or so years ago
a scholar who's a professor at indiana
now
named domenico melli
got his hands on
a leibniz manuscript called the ten
tamin which was leibniz's attempt
to produce an alternative to newton's
mechanics
and it comes to some conclusions that
you have in the newton's mechanics well
he published that but mellie got the
manuscript and what mellie found out was
that leibniz reverse engineered the
principia and cooked it backwards
so that he could get the results he
wanted
those for the mechanics so that means
his mind allows for that kind of thing
some people
you're breaking some use today you're
starting some people
some people think so i think most
historians of mathematics do not agree
with that uh a
friend of mine rather well-known
physicist unfortunately died a couple
years ago named mike nauenberg at uc
santa cruz uh had some evidence along
those lines didn't pass mustard
with many of my friends who are
historians of math in fact i edit with a
historian of meth a technical journal
and
we were unable to publish it in there
because we couldn't get it through
any of our colleagues
but i am i remain suspicious
you